one-year-old girl mina is severely
malnourished
but her family who've just fled from the
taliban in afghanistan cannot afford to
see a doctor
they don't know what to do next but for
the moment they
[Music]
this man arrived to get medical
treatment after he was hit by shrapnel
as government forces collapsed
there is now a steady trickle of people
starting to come across the border
at the chamin spin baldac crossing
but the authorities say the country
won't be able to cope with much larger
numbers
if this crisis worsens
there is no doubt this is a pivotal
moment the withdrawal has engendered a
huge amount of uncertainty in pakistan
the government here says it is already
host to as many as four million afghan
refugees and if there is another mass
exodus because the state collapses the
consequences will be dangerous not just
for this region
but for the world
pakistan's foreign minister says the
west must now engage with the taliban or
risk the prospect of a new civil war
the international community has to
wear the options
one option is engagement
as opposed to isolation
you know we've withdrawn
let's wash our hands we've done our bit
you know we leave
that's a dangerous option do you think
they have changed do you think they can
be trusted at this moment in time
i i what i'm saying is
test them
test them
before trusting them
they've made statements
let's see if they live up to them
and if they do
then build on it
because
the other option is far worse
one phase of this crisis may be drawing
to a close but with food shortages and
much of the country hungry as
afghanistan deals with its worst drought
in 30 years
people are scared about what comes next
alex rossi sky news
islamabad